food i love eating it talking about it
watching it on tv here is some delicious
kitchen inspiration
hi drew i'm jesse founder of life as a
strawberry and today i'm teaching you
how to make my favorite simple cranberry
sauce for the holidays
start by adding 12 ounces of cranberries
to a small saucepan with a bit of maple
syrup and honey this is going to help us
balance out the tartness of these
cranberries add a splash of water and
the juice of one orange slice then tuck
that orange right into the pot along
with everything else
add a pinch of salt and half of a
cinnamon stick for some great depth of
flavor then stir it all up and cook over
low heat for 15 to 20 minutes just until
the cranberries start to burst and break
down
remove the orange slice and the cinnamon
stick from the pot and if you don't love
this chunky cranberry sauce you can use
an immersion blender to smooth it all
out a little bit before you serve
this is a great make ahead recipe you
can serve it immediately or let it cool
and store it in the fridge for up to a
week or the freezer for several months
when you're ready to eat top with a bit
of fresh orange zest and enjoy
that recipe looks wow
[Music]